joe biden is not just bad on covet he's
also just terrible on the economy right
there's a reason his approval ratings
are 33 according to quinnipiac i cannot
get over that stat that stat is
astonishing inflation has now hit its
hottest rate since 1982 since 1982
according to the wall street journal u.s
inflation its fastest pace in nearly
four decades last year as
pandemic-related supply and demand
imbalances along with stimulus intended
to shore up the economy push prices up
at a seven percent annualized rate
the labor department said wednesday the
consumer price index rose seven percent
in december from the same month a year
earlier up from 6.8
in november
the so-called core price index which
excludes food and energy climbed 5.5 in
december from a year earlier which was a
bigger increase than november's 4.9
percent rise the highest rate since
1991.
this is because we blew an enormous
amount of money into the system in 2020
and then joe biden decided we need more
of that more of that in 2020 21 and it
was a disaster area this sort of
inflation by the way is brutalizing
workers
according to the wall street journal the
biden powell price increases reduced
real wages by 2.4 in 2021.
so you got a pay cut in 2021.
according to the wall street journal
it's important to understand what a
policy and intellectual failure this
inflation represents for keynesians who
are in charge of current economic policy
the biden administration and federal
reserve flooded the economy with money
in 2021 even as the recovery from the
covered recession was over
fed chairman jerome powell became a
cheerleader for the 1.9 trillion dollar
march spending spree on top of about 4
trillion in coveted relief congress
spent in 2020 the central bank also
declined to withdraw its extraordinary
monetary support despite clear signs of
incipient inflation
when critics began to warn of excess
monetary growth and price increases the
sages at the fed and white house
dismissed it as transitory
that failure is reminiscent of the 70s
when keynesians also ran the economy but
had no explanation for the inflation
that took off or for the stagflation
that later set in as that awful decade
rolled on they blamed corporations they
rolled out whip inflation now buttons
and imposed price controls
only at the end of the decade after
inflation became a political liability
for democrats to jimmy carter appoint
paul volcker to the fed
joe biden remains in denial he said
today's report which shows a meaningful
reduction in headline inflation over
last month with gas prices and food
prices falling demonstrates we are
making progress in slowing the rate of
price increases
but actually core prices without food
and energy increased from the pace of
the previous month
and this entire price is being paid by
people who are in the middle class if
you're rich you can afford this if
you're in the middle class or if you're
in the lower class in terms of earning
you cannot afford it you just cannot
and by the way the supply chain crisis
continues to marinate and percolate p
buddha judge a potential presidential
candidate thanks to the fact that he's
gay the secretary of transportation
who's presided over the largest supply
chain crisis of my lifetime and went
missing for two months to be on
paternity leave
when no one had suffered any sort of
physical trauma at all
because of course he and his husband
adopted a child
pete budaj he um he says that the supply
chain problems are going to continue
this guy wants to run for president
what we know is as long as there is a
pandemic it will be creating disruptions
now the good news is we found a lot of
steps that we can take including in the
short term that have made a huge
difference but if we have to bring in so
many goods from overseas that a shipping
issue or a factory closure thousands of
miles away stops us from getting what we
need that's a problem
oh well
yes it's it's all about what's happening
overseas by the way producer prices
skyrocketed 10 in december that's the
biggest gain ever recorded according to
fox business the producer price index
surged 9.7 in december from the year ago
period
it's just incredible
but all of this contributes to the fact
that the democrats are in serious
serious trouble according to the center
for politics larry sabato at the
university of virginia he is no
republican larry sabato points out that
this is going to be a massive year for
republicans
he says that the republicans could be
picking up
tons and tons of seats
he says in 2020 the republicans won 213
seats just five seats shy of a majority
republicans are starting this cycle with
roughly 35 more seats than they held in
advance of 1994 and 2010 and democrats
are not very overextended at least based
on the 2020 presidential results they
only one seven seats trump carried for
president
however the potential exists for
democrats to have for republicans who
have a blockbuster 2022 election
according to sabato
when assessing the gop potential in 2020
in 2022 they think the number they have
in mind is 35 that would give
republicans a 248 house majority house
seat majority eclipsing their 247th
victory in 2014 as the largest
republican house majority since the
great depression
they think that this is quite plausible
democrats are in serious trouble and
they can whistle past the graveyard by
suggesting their opponents are racist
it's just not going to work
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment